zur heutigen Pressekonferenz hier in der
rossauerlände begrüßen an meiner Seite
darf ich begrüßen die
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
und den Leiter des der budgetabteilung
Herrn Brigadier ditetm schin Frau
Verteidigungsministerin bitte um ihre
Worte ja sehr geehrte Herr Brigadier
schin sehr geehrte Brammer sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der Medien die letzten
Jahre haben uns als österreichisches
Bundesheer als Ressort intensivst
gefordert hat begonnen von der
coronakrise über den ukrainekrieg als
aktuelles Beispiel die
Auseinandersetzung in Nahen Osten das
zeigt eine seine Zunahme an
geopolitischen Spannungen und es zeigt
dass sich das sicherheitspolitische
Umfeld der Europäischen Union und damit
auch Österreichs massiv verschlechtert
hat und das mit Sicherheit keine
Besserung in Sicht ist es wurde ja erst
gestern seitens des Bundesministeriums
für für Inneres die Terra wahnstufe auch
erhöht das was wir sehen das ist dass
der Informationskrieg dass der Krieg der
Bilder durch diese Konflikte voll
ausgebrochen ist dass die Bevölkerung in
unterschiedlichsten Ländern hoch
emotionalisiert ist und es außer Frage
steht dass diese aktuellen Fälle ein
hohes
Eskalationspotenzial für weitere
militärische Auseinandersetzungen haben
wir sind
ohne Zweifel mit einer neuen Realität
konfrontiert und diese verlangt eines
eine Stärkung der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung insbesondere mit dem
Fokus auf die militärische
Landesverteidigung zum Schutz der
österreichischen Bevölkerung und zur
Wahrung der Souveränität der Republik
Österreich darauf müssen wir unser
Augenmerk setzen für uns als Bundesheer
bedeutet diese wirklich drastische
krisenhafte Entwicklung dass wir unserer
Verantwortung nachkommen müssen dass wir
stets vorbereitet sein müssen es zeigt
uns sehr deutlich dass gezielte
umfassende Investitionen in unser
Bundesheer und die Weiterentwicklung
unseres heres in Richtung einer modernen
Armee unabdingbar sind sie wissen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren dass wir
bereits letztes Jahr das höchste
Verteidigungsbudget in der Geschichte
des Bundesheeres hatten mit ,3
Milliarden Euro für das Jahr 2023 wir
sind hier an dieser Stelle gemeinsam mit
dem Bundeskanzler und dem Finanzminister
auch gestanden es freut mich besonders
dass nach den diesjährigen
Budgetverhandlungen nun für uns für das
österreichische Bundesheer ein
landesverteidigungsbudget von rund 18
Milliarden Euro in den nächsten vier
Jahren zur Verfügung stehen wird sie
wissen wir haben immer von einem Invest
von 16 Milliarden gesprochen für den
nächsten vier Jahre jetzt sind es 18
Milliarden von 2024 bis
2027 das ist eine Steigerung des Budgets
in konkreten Zahlen von
2,175 Milliarden Euro im Vergleich zum
bundesfinanzrahmen 2023 bis
2026 das heißt beginnend mit rund 4
Milliarden im Jahr 2024 ansteigen auf 5
Milliarden im Jahr
2027 das bedeutet dass das Budget 2023
in Höhe von 3,3 Milliarden Euro im Jahr
2024 auf 4,01 Milliarden steigen wird
das heißt auch dass wir mit diesen
Budgetzahlen im Jahr 2024 erstmals die
Summe von 4 Milliarden Euro durchbrechen
werden und ja wiederum das historisch
höchste Budget in der Zweiten Republik
für unser Bundesheer für die Sicherheit
Österreichs haben werden diese Erhöhung
und der eine oder andere von Ihnen hat's
ja schon berichtet entspricht einer
Steigerung des Budgets von zum Vorjahr
von
21% plus das viel wichtigere aber als
zahlen ist was wir mit diesem mehr am
Budget machen und wie wir dieses
verwenden werden mit dem mehr am Budget
erhöht sich selbstverständlich auch der
Investitionsanteil für uns und zwar
massiv das heißt in der budgetkategorie
Invest haben wir im Jahr
2024 im Vergleich zum Vorjahr eine
66%zentige Steigerung und sie wissen
dass der
investanteil am Gesamtbudget rund
30% beinhaltet das heißt für das Jahr
2024 werden wir noch mehr in
militärisches Gerät in Ausrüstung
investieren können ich darf ja nur ein
paar Beispiele nennen sie sinden ja
schon die große Investition der
Mehrzweck Hubschrauber bekannt insgesamt
36 Leonardo AW
169m wir modernisieren unsere
Fahrzeugflotte auf allen Ebenen wir
modernisieren die persönliche Ausrüstung
der Soldatinnen und der Soldaten es ist
unabdingbar notwendig dass wir neue
Transportflugzeuge erhalten Sie wissen
diesen Auftrag habe ich im ersten Jahr
meine Amtszeit bereits gegeben wir
werden investieren in die
aufklärungsfähigkeit in Digitalisierung
in Kommunikationsmittel allein wenn man
sich unsere LKW Flotte anschaut wir
werden die auf den absolut neuesten
modernsten Stand bringen das heißt plus
850 neue LKWs die bereits bestellt sind
insgesamt dann eine Flotte von 1050 LKWs
auf dem modernsten Stand nebenbei all
das sind auch Investments in die
österreichische Wirtschaft die
Arbeitsplätze auch sichern gerade wenn
wir z.B von pantur sprechen oder eben
auch von den LKWs die unweit hier in
Wien eben
von man reinmetall erzeugt produziert
werden
das was wichtig ist bei allen
Beschaffungen die ja durchaus auch Zeit
in Anspruch nehmen ist dass wir
Planbarkeit haben Planbarkeit haben mit
dem
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
das ist die Grundlage die reicht bis ins
jah 2032 und darüber hinaus und wir
können so unsere militärischen
Fähigkeiten ganz klar entwickeln das ist
auch notwendig eine strategische
Neuausrichtung des österreichischen
Bundesheeres die wir mit einem neuen
Kräfte Profil ja begonnen haben die
operative Umsetzung die im Aufbauplan öb
200 ÖBH 2022 plus jetzt konsequent
fortgesetzt werden kann wir wollen oder
wir müssen auch das ist alles Steuergeld
dass wir investieren wir müssen auch
transparent sein dabei und daher werden
wir haben wir bereits ein
landesverteidigungsbericht 2023 aners
Parlament übermittelt wo man immer auch
Sie
das risikobild von dem ausgehend welche
Fähigkeiten müssen weiterentwickelt neu
entwickelt werden was ist bereits
investiert beschafft worden wo stehen
wir um hier wirklich absolut transparent
auch den Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahlern gegenüber zu sein ja
Investitionen die in Wahrheit
jahrzehntelang auf der Strecke geblieben
sind ich habe ja schon die Beispiele
erwähnt wo wir dringenden Bedarf haben
sie sind ja informiert auch dass wir
insbesondere beim pantur Evo eine
weitere Beschaffung auch anregen werden
das Ziel ist das Ziel ist ja dass wir
dann über
320 in der Truppe in Verwendung auch
haben werden wir haben auch die weitere
Staffel Blackhawk 70 bereits kund getan
Transportsystem Herkules ist ebenfalls
schon angesprochen worden Investitionen
in unsere Infrastruktur in die autie der
einem genauen Bauplan auch folgen aber
an dieser Stelle auch ganz offen eine
ganz große Herausforderung in unserem
Ressort wird neben den Beschaffungen
ohne Zweifel auch das Personal
sein der öffentliche Dienst kämpft um
das Personal aber in Wahrheit ist es
auch in der gesamten Privatwirtschaft
eines der Hauptthemen wie man die
entsprechend gut
ausgebildeten Menschen auch bekommt die
dann bei uns eben als Soldatinnen und
Soldaten unser neues Equipment auch
bedienen können wir stehen vor einer
großen Pensionierungswelle und wir haben
bereits damit begonnen Maßnahmen zu
setzen um dem entgegen zu wirken und und
sehr vieles überlegt wie wir den
öffentlichen Dienst entsprechend
attraktiv gestalten können das
Wichtigste für uns im Bundesheer ist
dass wir nach wie vor die whrpflicht
haben dass wir alljährlich in etwa 16000
grundwerdiner bekommen für die wir
erstmalig nach 10 Jahren auch den Sold
erhöht haben wir haben den Freiwilligen
grundwertdienst für Frauen auch ins
Leben gerufen der besser angenommen
worden ist als wir uns das vorgestellt
hätten das sind die ersten Maßnahmen das
ist ein Potential an Grund wir Ihen dass
wir in Zukunft noch viel viel besser
auch nützen müssen und nützen werden
gerade wenn wir daran denken dass wir im
Jahr 800 Abgänge pro Jahr eben haben das
heißt das Augenmerk muss darauf gesetzt
werden das betrifft sowohl die
Berufssoldaten und die Zivilbediensteten
aber insbesondere auch die Miliz m es
ist nicht nur eine Frage des Geldes das
ist es auch aber ist eine andere Frage
auch noch wie man mehr am Personal
gewinnen oder das ist vielleicht auch
ein wichtiger Punkt dieses Personal
halten kann das heißt wir müssen neue
Möglichkeiten anbieten im Punkto
Karriere auf stieg entsprechende
Arbeitsplätze eben um die
Personalressourcen auch effektiv
einsetzen zu können ein ganz wichtiger
Bereich ist der und nicht nur für Frauen
sondern auch für Männer das ist der
Bereich der Vereinbarung Vereinbarkeit
von Beruf und Familie wir müssen an dem
weiterarbeiten das reicht von
Kinderbetreuungsmöglichkeiten die wir
anstreben jede Kaserne soll am Ende des
Tages
Kinderbetreuungsmöglichkeiten haben oder
eben andere incentivs die wir gerade in
unserem besonderen Ressort anbieten
können das war uns von Anbeginn an
wichtig dass wir die Truppe stärken um
den Aufbauplan 2032 plus mit unserer
Mission vorwärts auch in personeller
Hinsicht umsetzen zu können es geht
schrittweise voran aber gerade der
Bereich des Personals da gibt es noch
unglaublich vieles zu tun wir haben uns
im Rahmen der Mission vorwärts dieses
und viele weitere Ziele gesetzt um unser
österreichisches Bundesheer zu einer
modernen Armee auch aufzurüsten unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten auszurüsten und
damit die Sicherheit Österreichs in eine
neue Zukunft zu führen danke
schön ich würde nun den Leiter der
budgetabteilung Herrn Brigadier dimchine
um seine Ausführungen ersuchen ja vielen
Dank vielen Dank Frau Bundesminister für
die
Ausführungen ich bin seit 20 Jahren
bereits im budgetbereich tätig und das
was in den letzten 7 Jahren passiert ist
habe ich mir nie zu träumen gelassen wir
haben das Budget fast verdoppelt 2027
Frau Bundesminister hat das angesprochen
werden wir fast die 5 Milliarden Euro
erreichen vorgs Jahr haben wir etwas
erreicht was alle anderen armen bereits
haben oder viele Armen bereits haben
nämlich ein
landesverteiligungsfinanzierungsgesetz
und in diesem
ist es ganz ganz wichtig bekennt sich
die Bundesregierung also jede
Bundesregierung dass sie den bundesher
die notwendigen Mittel zur Verfügung
stellen
wird wir in diesem Bundes in diesem
landesverteungs finanzierungsgesetz
gibt's die erläuternde Bemerkungen und
diese erläuternde Bemerkungen sagen dass
das Bundesheer dass das Budget für das
Bundesheer in weiterer Folge auf
1,5% des Pips bis 2028 ansteigen sollte
und bis diesen 1,5% des biips können wir
auch den Aufbauplan den die Frau
Bundesminister angesprochen hat auch
erreichen im Endeffekt die
Schwierigkeiten die ich sehe im Budget
abgesehen von den Zahl von den Zahlen
ist ja das alles was einen privaten
Haushalt trifft trifft uns genauso das
heißt bei uns wird auch die Energie
teurer die Personalkosten die
Personalkosten steigen wir wir heizen
die Mieten steigen und so weiter und so
fort das zweite Problem die Frau
bundesmin hat auch ang angesprochen ist
das Personal das ist in allen das ist
sowohl in zivilen Sektor als in
öffentlichen Bereich auch so aber wir
starten jetzt eine Mission wir haben
bereits gestartet in Mission vorwärts
das heißt wir werden die Kontingente die
Aufnahme Kontingenten erhöhen für die
Militärakademie bis jetzt war 55
Offiziere in Zukunft s 120 sein bei den
Unteroffizieren wollen wir 600 50
Unteroffizier in Zukunft aufnehmen pro
Jahr und auch bei die Zivilbediensteten
die nicht verlachläsigt werden dürfen
weil sie die gesamte Logistik fast
tragen s s in Zukunft 500 zusätzliche
Soldaten Zivilisten sein und auch die
milizoffiziere sollen erhöht werden die
ausmustungsrate soll bei den Offizieren
auf 150 ansteigen und auf 610 bei den
Unteroffizieren das wär es im kurzen von
der Sicht von der Sicht aus der
budgetabteilung die Frau Bundes
gesagt im nächsten Jahr steigt unser
Investitionsbudget um
66% um 66% wenn mE einen natovergleich
hernimmt wir haben insgesamt wen muss
ein Budget aufteilt im Personal Betrieb
und Investition wir haben ungefähr 45%
im Personal aber wir haben bereits 30%
30% in der Investition damit sind wir
momentan über den natoschnitt danke
sehr gibt es
Fragen Jörg Hofer von der Zeit im Bild
ORF Frau Bundesminister sie haben ein
Thema ausgespart nämlich das der
Nachfolge für eurofitter und oder SAB
wie sieht's denn da aus ich habe nicht
nur ein Thema ausgespart sondern sehr
viele weil wir im Beschaffungsbereich
auf allen Ebenen Nachholbedarf auch
haben was die Eurofighter anbelangt das
sind 15 Stück die die aktive
Luftraumüberwachung durchführen und wie
es auch im Aufbauplan festgehalten ist
und jetzt auch aktualisiert im
landesverteidigungsbericht sich
wiederfindet werden auch unsere
eurofight auf den neuesten Stand
gebracht insbesondere in zwei Bereichen
was die
nachtidenentifizierungsfähigkeit
anbelangt und was den Selbstschutz
anbelangt es hat do ein Angebot gegeben
von zwei Sitzer eurofighn Abfangjägern
seitens der deutschen Bundeswehr das ist
derzeit aber bei uns noch in Prüfung was
die Nachfolge der ausgesch schedenen sa
105 anbelangt haben wir e mit dem
entsprechenden Budget jetzt die
Möglichkeit da auch eine Nachbeschaffung
durchzuführen wir streben ein Gerät an
das nicht nur für Übungszwecke oder für
die Ausbildung eingesetzt werden kann
sondern insbesondere auch so wie es
früher bei der SA allerdings nur in
einem kleinen Bereich am Schluss nur mit
mit 6% für die aktive Luftraum
Überwachung auch eingesetzt werden kann
und wir gehen davon aus dass wir im
Beginn im ersten Quartal 2024 die
nächsten Schritte dazu auch verkünden
können gibt
es bitte zu warten kurz bis das Mikrofon
da ist dürf man die Frage noch mal
Stellen bleiben die österreichischen
Soldaten im Libanon oder gibt's
Überlegungen sie komplett abzuziehen
oder einen Teil abzuziehen die Situation
dürfte sicher in den nächsten Tagen und
Wochen W möglich verschärfen was sind da
die Pläne oder bleiben sie auf jeden
Fall bis Jahresende ja Sie wissen dass
wir unser dritt größtes Kontingent neben
den eingesetzten
Kosovo und bei EF Alter im Libanon im
Libanon haben das sind im Moment über
250 Soldatinnen Soldaten es ist auch
heute wieder schelteralarm oder was
gestern eine geschelteralarm ausgelöst
worden es gibt seitens der Vereinten
Nationen einen einheitlichen
Evakuierungsplan aber soweit ist es
momentan nicht wir wissen es hat ja
diese Situation schon einmal gegeben das
war im Jahr 2006 damals dass auch damals
die Soldaten im Rahmen auch des Camps
eher noch sicher waren we die
entsprechenden eben Schelter hier auch
vorgesehen sind die auch benutzt werden
und wenn eine Entscheidung notwendig
sein sollte dann trifft die
selbstverständlich die vereinten die
Vereinten Nationen wir gemeinsam wie
gesagt hier gibt's selbstverständlich
ganz genaue ganz genaue Pläne
also es gibt keine alle
nein nachdem es keine weiteren Fragen
zum
landesverteidigungsbudget mehr gibt darf
ich diese Pressekonferenz für beendet
erklären und für weitere Fragen
ansonsten an meiner Seite Herrn Oberst
des generalstabsdienstes Markus Brammer
zur Verfügung stellen danke sehr danke
ih den
vielmals danke Frau Bundesminister DANKE
DANKE
SCHÖN
dankeen
Dank